I do I do congratulate the Prime
Minister he has secured a Tory majority
something that nobody thought was
possible and there was an earthquake in
this election and it happened north of
the border
it happened in Scotland I don't think
what you saw were a lot of voters so
scared of that Labour SMD coalition that
they shifted towards the Conservatives
and that included some of the people
here who voted you Kip last time round
but I saw another shift in this election
and I saw you kept the party apparently
for the retired old journals suddenly is
the party for people under 30
particularly young working women there
is a big change going on in politics and
I think what's really interesting I
think what's really interesting we've
always been here to believe that Britain
needs to get back its democracy we
shouldn't be governed from Brussels but
what is interesting is what's happening
within our democracy in this country
we've got a party in Britain who've got
50% of the vote in one of the regions
and nearly a hundred percent of the
seats and we've got another party that
scored nearly as many votes four million
as one ously European elections last
year that has finished up with one seat
in parliament and I think the time has
come for real genuine radical political
reform and it's UK that'll be the party
that leads it on a personal level
on a professional level I expressed to
their degree of disappointment on a
personal level I feel an enormous weight
has been lifted from my shoulders I've
never felt happier thank you